your highness your excellencies ladies
and gentlemen Salaam alaikum
good evening Maggie McDonald on behalf
of all Canadians from one teacher to
another congratulations on winning the
global teacher prize 2017
you chose to teach at the acoustic
school in celle wheat
a remote village in the Canadian Arctic
there are no roads to sell wheat it's
only accessible by air and it gets cold
really cold minus 20 this time of year
it's a fair meant no Cesar Chavez on
signal ABBA language Marcos every demo
ka-blammo
unique in Hamas God come visit CBN
Boozer less Sun is leg ha ha ha hey sis
on earth he was I speak with a very
seedy shows extraordinary circumstance
exceptional if there is a club the
nominal the car novelty is imagination
hello Missy McGee 7x plus anyway abs in
some toast classy a little I would also
like to thank His Highness Sheikh
Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum thank you
for your support of the teaching
profession in this prize and your
continued efforts to promote peace and
understanding I also congratulate the
Varkey foundation for your commitment to
education throughout the world and
finally I'd like to say thank you to
every teacher out there teachers own
responsibility to many people the
students to parents to the community to
the school board but in the end as all
great teachers know they are ultimately
responsible to something far greater
they are responsible to the future and
for the world that will be shaped by the
children that they teach sure Maggie
would be the first to say that the
global teacher prize is a tribute to all
teachers wherever they are so to our
winner our 10 finalists and to every
dedicated teacher around the world thank
you and enjoy the rest of your evening
you